okay here's the question do you think
this would translate well into a hentai
yeah dude if [ __ ] pink pineapple made
this hell yeah
i'm there wait did this not get a hentai
no no i stayed at home succubus got one
yeah yeah the other one the other one
got it i don't know like what
what i think wouldn't translate well is
that the [ __ ] [ __ ] scenes here are
so intense i couldn't see it translating
well
into hentai yeah might be able to be
done i don't know maybe
science will advance and we'll get good
technology to be honest
it'll be a it'd be like a 20 minute bj
scene so yeah
they have this story where okay so they
just start [ __ ] him and then
apparently his you know his pp is so
good that they're like we made a website
about your dick oh yeah they made it
viral didn't they they made him go viral
like oh by the way we've
put your dick online don't worry by the
way we haven't show your face yeah
yeah of course uh but your dick's famous
now to all the other succubus in the
world
and then like oh okay there's more
it's an idle handshake thing where you
can come and instead of hand shaking
idle yeah
suck the dick yeah yeah so so these
succubus they're like hundreds of
succubus show up to this
handshaking event where they're shaking
yeah yeah where they get where they pay
them
an amount of money to get like five
minutes to uh
milk the cow right that's that's the
best way to describe it right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah pretty
much um that was probably my favorite
chapter
i'm just like that was one [ __ ]
intense chapter yeah
just just i'd cause normally i'm like
i'm not into like the whole harem angle
of it
but it was so like the concept was so
overdone
and the art was so great and it was just
some of the scenes were so [ __ ]
intense that i'm just like yeah that's
hot
all right that's that
it's very good very good very good stuff
getting flashbacks
this is this is one where it's like if
i'm suffering to like
you know pick one for the job
yeah this is the conflict this is the
one that i always go back to yeah i mean
the reason i picked this one
is because like out of out of every
dojinshi if i were to pick one
where i'm introducing someone to like
the world of dojinshi and
what it's like then this one's just like
this one's just like an all-rounder in
every category
right don't miss it don't miss
this is the [ __ ] naruto of hentai
okay it's it's the gateway drug
okay
i mean yeah because like the content
like the tags are so inoffensive where
it's like it's not
too weird where it's like oh i'm not
really into that like everyone's into
[ __ ] djs
like who doesn't love [ __ ] right who
wouldn't want
three succubuses you know i mean that's
i mean you know
this is this is the equivalent this is
such a god i wish that would me
and it's okay right because it's
succubuses right so if you're not too
early that's like great they like that
that's what they want
yeah no disappointment oh god
yeah i mean what i liked is that they
gave context to you know you know
normally like a hentai protagonist can
orgasm like an ungodly amount of times
yeah yeah i like the fact that they gave
it a reason
for him to be able to orgasm that amount
of time which is just like
like if you feed on the pheromones or
something they have no yeah they have
pheromones and if you like
like feed on their spit or something
yeah yeah it's always the saliva yeah if
you swap like
if you swap body fluids then it's just
like like this
[ __ ] mega aphrodisiac yeah and the
semen is like an aphrodisiac for the
succulent
that's like a two for a never-ending
cycle oh god the perfect system doesn't
exist
in this story after they they have this
whole handshaking event
uh they put his face online anyway yeah
they're like come
come guys look how amazing this guy is
yeah and then suddenly
a [ __ ] sudden dairy lolly shows up
and i'm like what's all this
are you
because i didn't know which which one of
you did this right yeah yeah that was
what tilted it in the head
i was like i was like [ __ ]
oh yeah this remember yeah i remember
first reading that
and then she's like hello i am the
mother
and then i was like i was like literally
the headset meme of like
taking the headset you had it
you had it why did you introduce a
[ __ ] lolly
it was so good so because what's so
funny is that she's technically
a lolly milf right
it's the both worlds everybody wins
literally i wasn't even wearing a
headset but i metaphorically pulled one
out
for that meme i'm like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
just did the movement [ __ ]
it was so bad god it was it was so
perfect you know i was enjoying life it
was great you know and this happened
it ruined it for me
and she got a whole own section i was
like no one else got their own section
why do you get your own section they do
later on but at this point no one else
had their own section at this point
why does the [ __ ] lolly who just
showed up looking like a [ __ ] bratz
doll
get to have a whole [ __ ] 20 pages
what's this
i don't want this i'm like [ __ ] speed
running this [ __ ] trying to get it over
with
like when is anything else gonna happen
and then luckily luckily it saved itself
the next and then the next chapter
and then suddenly they introduced our
like oh by the way there's a union for
succubus because of course there
and they have a headquarters yeah yeah
he gets shipped off to like the [ __ ]
u.n or something right
the [ __ ] u.n of succubus gets shipped
off and then they're like by the way
succubuses have been stopping wars for
generations because we [ __ ] people into
submission
so no wars because everyone is happy
because we [ __ ] them
and it's like oh okay i mean i guess
that i guess it makes sense
yeah of course god i gotta introduce
some world building somewhere yeah
i have wars if you're [ __ ] right geez
and then uh yeah i really like that
woman she was great she was very
attractive i very much like
it looks like a milk oh yeah she does i
thought she was
she was right up my alley i was like
this is great you do look like an office
lady tag
yeah because she was also you know she
was also like oh no i don't want it
don't want it but then she did want it
but it was obvious the whole time yeah
yeah [ __ ] yeah of course yeah of course
yeah it wouldn't have been such a shame
on twitter
and she's like one and he's like
understandable i want to watch a porno
where the plumber comes and just fixes
something
and then just leaves and then she just
masturbates
i want that that's very available my
expectations you know give me something
throw me a curveball you know
you know maybe we're deconstructing
porno now yeah exactly
uh yeah but i mean i think i wrote down
i said this would have been a 10 out of
if they didn't have the [ __ ] lollipop
the lolly intrusion as i called it
intrusion oh my god i yeah i mean i
i wrote the art as god tier like pretty
much everything was god too i'm really
[ __ ] around with 8 out of 10 i mean
yeah it's
it was probably my favorite out of all
of these in terms of
could i not do it yeah yeah definitely
the that that does not surprise you just
like being just
pictures i think i could manage i think
yeah if i scroll really the first thing
i did when i looked at like the list
with gotten mine is like this is going
to be common this is going to be
famous i'm like this man likes vanilla
this is the most vanilla i mean it's
it's it's not so much vanilla as
so much as so it's just it's just
universally defensive
that this is god teardosian oh yeah it's
it's one of the best dojones ever made
some of the best art ever made um hasn't
yet gotten a hentai adaptation which i'm
just like
how has this not gotten hentai
adaptation i would appreciate an
adaptation to this
maybe all the studios are scared
and a queen bee cracking their knife
dude if queen bee adapts this i would
cry
so hard to take a shot at this just
comes from behind no because
what sucks about queen bee is that when
you it's like
every queen bee dogen that seems to get
adapted it adapted it's like
a dozen i respect like close to this
level right yeah it's it's a god
teardosian
that gets passed around you're like
brilliant looks [ __ ] fantastic
i mean i feel like when i when i see
people in the comments or these websites
we're like oh god it's queen bee i'm
just like i don't even know who this
this dojin is so i could have never been
disappointed what is this
and frankly i don't even know who you
are i literally don't even know who you
are so like it's not a problem but some
of them i still manage you know queen
bees does a good enough job sometimes
you're good enough right to get the job
done you know yeah yeah the
the task can be complete uh but yeah i
know i mean this is just great so i
highly recommend if you haven't read
gotta dudes read it wow connor
recommending dozens wow